before we move on to how linear
equations are plotted on the coordinate
plane let's quickly review what linear
equations in two variables are we've
seen equations like 2x plus 5y equals 12
or X minus y equals 4 and so on these
are examples of linear equations in two
variables each of the equations has two
variables x and y but how do we
generalize it how can we define it we
can say that a linear equation in two
variables is of the form ax plus B y
equals C or sometimes it's also written
as ax plus B y plus C equals 0 both are
correct for example the first equation
can also be written as 2x plus 5y minus
12 equals 0 for this video and the
future ones in this topic we will assume
the second one to be the general
equation for linear equations in two
variables ax plus B y plus C equals 0 a
B and C are constants while x and y are
variables a is the coefficient of x and
B is the coefficient of Y this is the
general form we will consider hold on
are there any conditions here yes first
the constants a B and C have to be real
number and the second condition is
addressing and I want you to listen to
it carefully both a and B cannot be 0
together yes it means at least one has
to be nonzero can you come up with a
mathematical way to write the second
condition
it's interesting and a very innovative
way to write it it can be written act a
squared plus B squared will not equal
zero this will implies that both cannot
be zero together because if both are
zero then the left hand side will equal
zero now let's just consider the first
equation we saw 2x plus 5y equals 12
what is the solution to this equation
the solution to a linear equation in two
variables is a pair of values one for X
and the other for Y which makes both the
sides of the equation equal can you
think of x and y values here which will
equate both the sides one possibility is
when X is one and Y is two so we can say
that x equals one and y equals two is
one of the solutions to the equation 2x
plus 5y equals 12 can you tell me if x
equals 3 and y equals 1 is the solution
to this equation
the answer is low if we substitute these
values on the left hand side we get a
value of 11 which is not equal to 12
so this pair of values is not a solution
to this equation now that we have a
basic idea about linear equations in two
variables we can move on to looking at
pairs of linear equations in two
variables
[Music]
you